if you were going to arm a screenwriter
with one tool or weapon what would it be
I'm assuming you're we're talking uh
what per screen variety I'm not walking
down the street yeah oh gosh that is a
really good question
writing wise it will always be the
ability to outline that to me as is one
of those tools that are completely
underrated that are rarely taught but
are integral because I can tell you all
of my clients who are represented before
they go to script it's always show me
the outline and this is not something
they're traditionally taught so for me
that the ability to outline cohesively
in five pages 10 pages 18 pages that is
the tool that to me is just underrated
and absolutely crucial
you